well Joe Rogan who has a small I'm told
this is an internet web show and some
sort of podcast or something uh he now
has come around this is a guy who was a
Hollywood guy Californian fled
California moved to Texas uh definitely
not what you'd call a traditional
Republican as he's a mushroom meeting
MMA fighting Ayahuasca doing uh you know
muscle bound meat head or something like
that uh well he knows that the red waves
are coming the Red Wave that's coming is
going to be like the elevator doors
opening up in The Shining
that's what I think I think people are
just like what the [ __ ] are you saying
they're making Republicans I don't know
how they're doing it it's I had a family
member who isn't who's a boomer and a
die-hard liberal and they told me when I
was home this Summer that they would
vote for DeSantis and I'm like how did
you lose this person yeah how did you
lose this person this is a this is a
like go to the ballot and vote blue no
matter what and you've lost even the the
Boomers
I love Bridget she's been on the show
many times she's she's a dear friend of
mine I know how they did it you know how
they did it they would not stop with the
woke stuff it's as simple as that the
Liberals would not defend liberalism
this is something I've been talking
about for a long time so all of the good
people the moderates The Joe Rogan types
the people who don't care about politics
that much finally first they look at
their wallets and they go none of this
makes sense right Elon Musk has to move
Tesla from California to Texas because
of tax purposes Rogan signs a 200
million dollar deal he's just looking at
the numbers and then he goes okay
Democrat run states have massive taxes
taxes has no income tax well that's one
part then you realize you don't want uh
your kids second grade teacher talking
to them about chopping their genitals
off that seems like a pretty much a
throwaway to me like we don't want that
so if you don't want that you'd be more
inclined to move to a red state if you
want your kids to be taught that America
is actually fundamentally decent and how
about we have an honest assessment of
what our founding is and what what our
history is well you could do that in
certain red States but it's getting
increasingly harder and harder to do in
blue States and in blue cities so you
might want to blow up the Department of
Education you might want to have less
centralized control you might realize
that say Randy Weingarten who's the head
of the teachers union is a Democrat
activist who for some reason was in
Ukraine two weeks ago there's a so much
weirdness here but it's all kind of
obvious if you've been paying attention
and I know you guys have